tien ii is a kung fu master who uses a
unique black tiger fighting style to
take down his opponents while he's away
his enemies the tian non three tigers
storm his mansion to kill the kung fu
master the assassins easily defeat tn2
security men as they advance through the
compound and enter the mansion's living
area there they find tientu's wife
together with his son chang and
immediately seize the frightened duo
they ask them about tien too but learn
that he is gone on a business trip this
enrages the trio and they immediately
kill the woman while they cut off
chang's arms seconds later tien 2
returns from his trip and is devastated
to discover what the assassins have done
he immediately attacks the trio and
engages them in a fierce battle an
enraged tn2 uses his bare hands and
disarms the assassins with a series of
fast-paced blows before killing them
with his deadly black tiger fighting
style after he is done with the
assassins he consoles his son chang and
vows to get him a pair of iron hands as
soon as his arms heal up years later
chang grows up to be a fine young man
and as promised gets a pair of
prosthetic iron arms to replace his
limbs moreover the iron arms can extend
in length as needed and shoot out darts
at the same time chang also learns the
deadly black tiger technique from his
father and becomes an exceptionally
skilled fighter in one of their training
sessions chang easily destroys several
bamboo trees showcasing great agility
and strength after the gruesome training
session tien tu takes chang to the
mansion's compound where a group of tied
up prisoners are waiting tientu reveals
to chang that the prisoners are the sons
of the assassins who crippled him years
ago as soon as chang hears this he
attacks the prisoners and cripples them
just as their fathers had done to him
however despite having their revenge
tientu and chang are still filled with
bitterness and anger towards the world
both father and son have turned into a
ruthless pair who terrorizes the town
and takes pleasure in crippling anyone
who offends them one day the father-son
duo accompanied by their lead bodyguard
juan arrives at a tavern there chang and
juan unjustly beat up two men who look
at them the wrong way seeing this the
town's blacksmith way becomes horrified
and loudly berates them for bullying the
man after wei leaves tientu plots with
juan to teach him a lesson later
meanwhile a traveling salesman named
chen also speaks out against the
family's barbaric actions the statement
greatly upsets chang prompting him to
approach and attack the salesman chen
doesn't get a chance to react as chang
swiftly uses his iron fists to poke
chen's eyes permanently blinding the
traveler as he stumbles to the floor in
pain in the following scene tien 2 sends
juan along with his other bodyguards to
bring the town's blacksmith way to his
mansion at the mansion way is instantly
seized by the guards and forced to drink
a strange liquid as a result he loses
his voice permanently devastated way
curses tien 2 by writing an inscription
on a nearby table sadly this bold action
pisses tien 2 off and he fiercely slaps
wei's ears making him deaf as well the
next day tientu and chang accompanied by
their entourage take a stroll around
town a man named akui mistakenly bumps
into chiang which causes the two men to
argue an abusive chang throws akui to
the ground and orders his bodyguards to
cut off akui's legs in the next scene
chang's disabled victims discover each
other and are bullied by some villagers
fortunately this doesn't last long as a
visiting kung fu master named yi comes
to their aid and chases the bullies away
yi also learns if tu's tyranny and
promises to avenge the cripples as he
swiftly walks to the master's mansion
there he meets tien2 alongside his
entourage and condemns the fighter's
violent actions his words prompt two of
tiantu's bodyguards to attack him but he
easily takes them down after a while the
lead bodyguard juan charges at yi and
the duo engages in a fierce battle
eventually chang joins the fight and
manages to capture yi with juan's help
tientu's men torture ye using an iron
vice to compress his skull sadly the
punishment results in ye suffering
severe brain damage making him mentally
disabled man life sure makes you
aggressive when you can't touch yourself
after this ye is thrown out of the
mansion and left to die luckily he is
helped by the other three cripples who
rescue him and take him to way's shop
the cripples ask ye multiple questions
to determine where he comes from however
a now idiotic yi merely jumps around
playfully right then akui searches yi
and finds a note from his teacher who
lives at a nearby kung fu school
learning this the four disabled men
embark on a journey to return yee to his
master wei uses a barrow to transport a
blind chen and a crippled akui while yee
fools around behind them eventually the
men arrive at the school but find its
doors tightly shot yi easily scales the
fence and enters the compound opening
the doors for the rest from the inside
the disabled men find yee's master jin
ying and tell the aged man about
tiantu's tyranny and his numerous
violent actions leading to their
respective disabilities jin ying is
horrified by the news and reveals that
tientu was once a hero who used his
fighting skills for good however he is
now turned into a monster after the
assassins attacked his home many years
ago the master thanks the cripples for
returning ye and to show his
appreciation offers to teach them kung
fu the men are ecstatic to hear this and
quickly accept the offer as they plan to
enact their revenge on tien ii and take
the tyrant down the next day jin yang
commences their training and uses a
unique teaching style for each man in
line with their disabilities he
instructs wei to make a pair of
prosthetic iron legs for akui after a
long day's work the blacksmith
successfully makes them and akui tries
them on he isn't used to the artificial
legs and shakily stands on his feet
before falling to the ground jin yang
also trains chen to use his sense of
hearing to supplement his lack of sight
chen learns to sharpen his ears and
eventually masters using them over time
chen is able to accurately shoot down
several falling leaves by just using his
keen hearing later the master teaches
way alongside the others a unique palm
sign language to communicate with the
deaf man jing ying uses the technique to
deliver multiple instructions to wei and
teaches him martial arts tricks such as
using reflective bands to see objects or
opponents moving behind him meanwhile
akui practices walking on the prosthetic
legs and gradually perfects using them
he also learns kung fu kicks and uses
his powerful metal legs to his advantage
on the other hand wang yi though
mentally disabled remains a skilled
martial arts master hence he requires no
further teaching he spends the entire
time mindlessly disturbing the other
cripples and occasionally practices with
them in their respective training three
years pass and the men fully complete
their training and become expert kung fu
fighters as they say their final
goodbyes to their master he gives them
some valuable intel on tien 2. the
tyrant is throwing a party in a few days
to celebrate his 45th birthday hence
that would be a perfect opportunity to
attack jin ying advises them to attack
tien 2 together and get used to the
fighter's black tiger style before
trying to finish him off the group
thanks him for his help over the years
after this they leave the school to
enact their revenge chen proposes they
return to town separately to observe any
new changes and avoid arousing suspicion
he disguises himself as a fortune teller
and re-enters the town as he arrives at
the tavern for a drink the tavern keeper
recognizes chen and quietly warns him
that tientu's top bodyguard juan is in
the room chen is amused by this and
walks over to one's table sitting with
the top guard while the other men stare
at him after conversing chen confidently
reveals to an unsuspecting juan that he
is the very same man his boss blinded
years ago the bodyguards swiftly attack
chen but he easily defeats them with his
quick-witted kicks and blows so much for
keeping a low profile juan also pounces
at chen and the duo engage in an intense
battle juan bombards him with several
punches but with the aid of his staff
chen dodges all of them ultimately chen
hits one with his staff which knocks him
back juan is startled by the blind man's
expert abilities and leaves the tavern
with his men soon after shortly
afterwards juan returns to the mansion
and hires a pair of fighting masters lin
and lou to defeat chen before tientu's
birthday the next morning wei also
arrives in town and visits the tavern he
is welcomed by the shop owner who leads
him to a special table upstairs to enjoy
a drink right then juan arrives with his
men and chases all the customers away
from the tavern while way hides upstairs
observing the group from the elevated
ground meanwhile juan orders the men to
remain still and to not make a sound as
they wait to ambush a blind chan just as
chen enters lynn shoots an iron ball at
him but way saves him by pushing a table
from upstairs to stop the shot the sound
alerts chen to the surrounding men and a
fight ensues juan and his men launch a
series of rapid attacks but the two
cripples dodged their blows and expertly
defeat them seeing this a cautious wand
signals his men to stop fighting and
retreats to the mansion that evening way
is attacked from behind by lou but the
deaf man spots him using a mirror
attached to his neck and dodges the
strike after a brief fight wade defeats
and kills lou while one of juan's men
observes from a distance a few minutes
later the witness shows one lou's corpse
and reveals that way was the one who
killed the skilled fighter the news
greatly disturbs juan prompting him to
devise a plan to kill the cripples
geez that night one and his men find
chen and way at the tavern one attacks
way and an intense fight ensues chen
tries to join the fight but wandsman
beat drums to hinder his hearing the
drumming sound confuses chen as he
frantically waves his rod around hitting
nothing but air fortunately wei comes to
his aid and charges towards the drumming
man when the noisy sounds stop chen
regains his composure and joins the
fight juan and his men rush the duo with
multiple sword swings but the cripples
easily disarm them using their
heightened senses way hits several
guards in the face with his fists while
chen wards them off by skillfully
swinging his staff juan and his men are
stopped by mr cho one of tiantu's old
friends who had just arrived in town for
his birthday this party's starting to
pop off cho a veteran fighter sends the
men away and assures them that he can
single-handedly defeat the duo when they
leave cho admits that he feels terrible
about fighting a pair of cripples and
makes them a proposition he offers them
three free punches and kicks before they
even start fighting just to even the
playing field instantly the duo accepts
the offer with whey punching and kicking
him three times however a sturdy cho
barely flinches chen also tries to knock
him down by delivering multiple attacks
and even a high kick but cho once again
remains unmoved right then akui and yi
emerge from the tavern's secret room and
join the others akui asks cho for his
free attacks and the boastful veteran
obliges akui strikes cho three times
with his fists but the latter remains
unaffected however when aku kicks him
with his iron feet cho is left brutally
injured he tries to fight the group but
they dodge his attacks after which he
succumbs to his injuries and dies while
remaining in a standing position akui
and yi return to the tavern secret room
while chen and wei stay behind juan
returns with his men and is shocked to
find that chen and wei are still alive
the men check cho and are shocked again
to discover that he is dead as the
mighty fighter falls to the floor
breaking a table in the process the men
carry his body back to the mansion and
throw it to tian ii informing the tyrant
of the cripple's return on tianti's
birthday he goes to the tavern to fight
the cripples chen aware that tiantu is
approaching instructs the group to leave
the building as soon as they engage the
tyrant in a fight and learn his
techniques akui also exits the tavern
before the men show up to conceal his
iron leg ability later on tian ii
alongside his men arrives at the tavern
chen and wei emerged and engaged the
tiger-style user in a battle but quickly
jump out through the window once he gets
the upper hand yee follows shortly after
and joins the duo as they escape tian
too decides not to pursue them and
instead spends the rest of the day in
his mansion entertaining his guests at
his party the next day the crippled
avengers regroup and storm tiantu's
mansion with chen and wei entering first
as they enter the compound tianti's
bodyguards who anticipated their arrival
launched several coordinated attacks at
them chen's hearing is impaired by the
bodyguard's drumming while whey is
blinded by the sun's rays reflected from
a contraption of mirrors luckily just as
the guards approach the duo ye enters
the scene startling the man as he
destroys some drums regaining their
senses the duo destroys the mirror
contraption and the rest of the drums
while simultaneously defeating the
guards chen and wei knock them all out
including juan and lin after which the
duo advances to the other end of the
mansion where they find tiantu and his
son chang the two cripples separate with
wei going after teon ii while chen
engages chang in a fight chang uses his
iron fists to deliver several swift
blows at the blind man but chan
tactfully uses his iron staff to block
them chen and chang are evenly matched
in skill as both men showcase
extraordinary speed and agility soon
after yi joins the fight and with his
help chen gains the upper hand chen and
yi use a pair of metal rings and launch
a coordinated attack at chang managing
to snap his neck in the process
sadly before chang falls he delivers a
fatal blow to yi severely injuring the
mentally disabled man who dies shortly
after chen takes a moment to mourn ye
but immediately joins way as the duo
fight teon 2 together a while later akui
also joins them and the trio
collectively battles the tiger-style
user the final battle is ferocious like
a tiger but unlike anything the cripples
had previously encountered the men used
the surrounding tables to their
advantage launching aerial kicks at tian
ii but the master fighter dodges the
attacks despite their number tiantu
keeps up with them and matches their
acrobatic movements after a lengthy
battle wei and chen immobilized tian ii
while akui delivers a finishing kick
with his iron feet the tyrant is
astonished by the power of akui's kick
and realizes that he has a pair of iron
feet however it is too late tiantu falls
to the ground due to the kick's impact
and dies the movie ends as the three
cripples leave the mansion with bright
smiles having successfully enacted their
revenge the moral of the story is that
revenge is never worth it but sometimes
it's worth it subscribe for more videos
like this turn on notifications and
leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching